how's it going resume welcome to another
oculus rift [ __ ] best intro ever that's
why I'm number one [ __ ] the number one
[ __ ] that is of course we're gonna play
affected on the oculus rift this game
looks cool it does look cool but it's on
the oculus and it's gonna make me cry
let's be honest I cry a lot
please wear headphones oh [ __ ] it
started just like that you can't get my
god no god what the what is up with my
eye Hey we go oh god it's like once he
put it on it's a completely different
thing man
select the floor then called the lift I
don't want to do any of this [ __ ] full
experience the acai silence and God you
know I need a break okay well I guess
we're going yeah that's two Z I don't
really walk like this I could just walk
myself but
Oh God all right we're here that matter
I bet for us don't ow I'm too tall okay
I bet it's not even that bad let's be
honest here I'm we're probably gonna die
within the five minutes so I think we're
off on a good hey you look good you're
like the painting in my room that's
awesome
I've got dead people we got ugly couches
oh god that is an ugly couch oh god this
is a truly horrifying place oh god I
forgot
Oh God oh guy I don't know how to
explain this president this is [ __ ]
crazy man it really feels like I'm
looking down a hole all away
all right I'm not scared
oh all right
rad regard you are you scared bro
run off for [ __ ] I can't no no no I
can't
I'm not exactly one bit this is oh [ __ ]
Oh Jeff Oh Jeff luck oh how did a good
boy a hell better
I saw y'all pull out that Oh had a good
okay this is so [ __ ] up
at least I can pause pauses my friend
here
oh [ __ ] Oh
Shh okay okay okay it's a plan that jab
blah is that what he held okay okay all
right no God what is a what is that oh
[ __ ] I forgot how [ __ ] terrifying
this is for the oculus okay I think
we're out of here no okay okay shut up
it's just a [ __ ] kid I'm not scared
of kids [ __ ] kids [ __ ] them all
I I will not [ __ ] them though that's
illegal but still not only we gots an
ugly face don't distract me with your
ugly face this game that doesn't work on
me
don't you sit in me okay there's no one
sitting there hello I'm 40 pi I came in
here like a rat yep that fixed on me
feet dumbest ahead in the best day I'm
gonna bust get it that card off turn it
off I mean Oh oh god what do I go I'll
take you don't appreciate it because I
was wasn't [ __ ] it up already shut up
everyone just shut your mouth I don't
like this I don't like McDonald's it
just makes me feel bad afterwards oh god
oh god oh god no no no no no no
what did that [ __ ] go where did the
[ __ ] go where is the [ __ ] oh god oh
god please hello what do i do oh okay
okay okay all right all right that was
not that bad
honestly that was an even big deal I
have recovered 110% I am a man man
doesn't get scared all right hey hey if
you get scared [ __ ] I'll make out with
you [ __ ] that's because I'm a man
I'm out of it where's the exit
I don't know how okay [ __ ] sake only
you know what if it wasn't for it was
your favorite shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut up
Oh God okay no no I can't
I'm sorry I can't play with your kids
I'm busy being awesome oh thank god
oh this oh whoa what you're not supposed
to fly all right you know come down here
right now a chair but I love it up here
pets I love it shut up
you come down right here you little
[ __ ]
sure what are you doing outside that
shut up
that ugly-ass [ __ ] ever I don't
understand why do you guys flying then
huh what are you going to cite each
other that's [ __ ] sexy all right you
know what I'm coming back for you
[ __ ] and when I come I will it will
not be pretty
[Music]
job done no no no no no no okay all
right oh [ __ ] I'm going I'm going too if
it wasn't children if it was a witch oh
god oh god no no oh god I'm going okay
okay
what this is not healthy there has to be
some health regulation - this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my tattoo D tat what was that we did
it oh it's a next up asylum ha ha ha
no nope yeah you think so that's what do
you think Levi can be doing watching
hits the sky hombre today and maybe just
maybe I will never play this again sales
and I love you back
[Music]